[Music]
welcome everyone i am your host john
perry
you are watching the stated casually
holiday special
angels
are fake
i'm kidding i'm joking calm down
everyone
here on the stated casually youtube
channel i teach biology and so far as i
can tell
you can't really use what we know from
the field of biology to say whether or
not angels exist
i'm sure that if you look down in the
comment section you'll find a nice
friendly debate
about things like under what conditions
can science confirm a negative could we
ever scientifically conclude for example
that bigfoot is definitely fake
probably not
but again i'm sure there's going to be a
nice civil conversation about this down
in the comments section because this is
the internet where civil calm discourse
happens
biology probably cannot tell us whether
or not angels are real but an appeal to
biology can tell us about their anatomy
at least the way their anatomy is
depicted in most christian art
now i totally get it those giant
feathery wings are beautiful
but they're fake they make absolutely
zero anatomical sense this has bothered
me since i was a child
allow me to explain
if you've only ever taken a casual
interest in birds you might not have
noticed that bird wings are modified
arms
this fact is fairly well hidden from the
outside because of all those feathers
but it quickly becomes clear if you look
at the underlying bone
notice that just like in the arm of a
human
a bird wing consists of one bone the
upper arm
two bones the forearm then wrist hand
and finger bones in most birds the
fingers are fused together making it
hard to see their fingery nature but
this is a chicken embryo as it develops
in the egg what the scientists did here
is they removed chickens at different
stages of development and then they
stained their bones with ink it's
actually more of a cartilage material at
this point but it becomes bone anyway
notice it starts out with three fingers
three reptile-like claws which gradually
fuse to form the wing
if you require further evidence still
let's go back and look at the fossil
record
early birds in the fossil record clearly
have wings and those wings are clearly
modified arms with hands this here is
archaeopteryx one of the earliest
feathered flyers if we compare his
fingers to the chicken
these are the same three fingers that
chickens have
smashed together inside their wings
other small dinosaurs might not have
been able to fly but probably could
glide
many birds today still do have claws on
the ends of their fused fingers
ostriches still have two claws on their
wings
and most breeds of chicken still have at
least one
even if you reject the idea that birds
evolved from dinosaurs
even if you reject evolution altogether
you still have to admit that wings are
modified arms
after seeing what i've just shown you no
rational human being could deny this
unless you think that i somehow just
made up all this evidence in which case
just go to the grocery store and dissect
a chicken yourself
okay so what wings are modified arms who
cares you might say maybe angels just
have two sets of arms one set of arms
are human-like one set of arms are
bird-like
okay again fair enough but how are those
wings connected to the angel's body
if you are the type who likes to eat
turkey for thanksgiving dinner you know
that the muscles connecting the wing to
the body are huge enormous pectoral
muscles also known as breast meat run
almost all the way down the front of a
bird's body if angels were real they'd
need normal pectoral muscles for their
human arms plus giant breast muscles for
their bird arms this possibility by the
way has been brilliantly illustrated
here by artist monica zagreb
i love that she actually went all the
way through this you can find anything
on the internet
a link to monica's article is down in
the video description
so
church folks and comic book artists who
like to draw angels take note
this is how you should be drawing your
angels anatomy
if you don't like this if it looks too
weird for you
this will
let's give her some music so she's not
shuffling around in silence
there we go
this woman does seem to have figured out
a reasonable alternative
just having the feathers come right off
the arms that is literally how birds do
it
my name is john perry
angel wings are fake
merry christmas
if you enjoyed today's science lesson
you should definitely subscribe to this
channel do that right now but also you
are invited to come hang out with me in
ecuador where my friend nancy and i are
planning an evolution tour of the amazon
jungle nancy is an entomologist a
scientist who studies bugs and she lives
in ecuador it will be a week-long tour
of the mountain range the cloud forest
and the amazon jungle we will hike
through the forests paddle around on
boats and in the evenings nancy and i
will give lessons on evolution kind of
like the one that you just watched here
but you know relevant to jungle stuff
you are guaranteed to see all sorts of
amazing wildlife that you've never seen
before
if lucky we might even see river
dolphins which i'm really excited about
i've never seen a river dolphin before
exact details are not available yet but
we do have a website where you can sign
up for our mailing list and see a bunch
of photos from past tours link to the
website is down in the video description
we're thinking it will be the week of
new year's day
2023 i know that's a ways out there i
suppose we could do it sooner but i want
the world to have a bit of a better
handle on covid before i invite a bunch
of people to travel across international
borders nancy is working with hotels and
a tour bus company so that everything
food lodging salaries and tips for the
local tour guides and all of your travel
within ecuador for eight days will be
less than two thousand per person
exactly how much less it's not clear yet
but again sign up for the newsletter and
we will get details to you as soon as we
know
it's gonna be awesome
hope to see you there
you